I think the biggest piece of advice that  I could give that the amateur cyclists  if you like is to really understand the  demands of the event and once you  understand the physical and the  physiological demands of that event then  you can really begin to plan detailed  fuel and strategies and I've got a  little bit of a saying actually that  there's no point fuel in the car if you  don't know how the engine works and it's  exactly the same with athletes  there's no point putting fuel into an  athlete if you don't know how the muscle  responds to exercise if you don't  understand the duration of that session  the intensity of the session so  sometimes you need a lot of fuel  sometimes you don't need a lot of fuel  at all so really if amateur athletes can  get into that habit of thinking what is  happening tomorrow because I need to  start thinking about tomorrow today the  same way that you plan your treinen  periodization you've also got a plan you  nutritional periodization